beste Stimmung herrscht am Donnerstag
beim militärmusikfestival 2023 im
Wörthersee Stadion in Kärnten
ich bin der Kärntnerin früher war ich
selber bei der postkapelle dabei 10
Jahre und jetzt spielen mit mir also
absolutes Gänsehaut gefühlt und es wird
halt echt besonders ich freue mich
riesig dass sie dabei bin ja ich freue
mich endlich auf den kurzen Abend auf
meiner Auftritt von ihm mit einer
Orchester Melia gespielt
und fantastisch organisiert das ganze
und 1000 militärmusikerinnen und Musiker
aus Österreich Italiens Slowenien
Montenegro und aus dem Oman begeistern
das Publikum den ganzen Abend lang
vor einer besonders großen Aufgabe
stimmt diesmal die Tontechniker des ORF
für die TV-Aufzeichnung sind und 180
Mikrofone im Einsatz 50 die fix
eingebaut sind an der Seite am Rasen und
so weiter und 130 die als Funkmikrofon
selbst eingebaut sind also kommt heute
ziemlich dran und es wird sehr spannend
werden für uns aber ich habe schon ein
bisschen eingehört es wird super werden
die gesamten spenden
gehen auch diesmal wieder an Licht ins
Dunkel die langjährige Kooperation
zwischen dem Verein und dem Bundesheer
ist mittlerweile zu einer lieb
gewonnenen Tradition geworden und das
aus einem guten Grund vor allem knappen
Jahr gab es große Unwetter im Gegenteil
da in Kärnten und weit von hier wo das
Bundesheer sofort rot waren geholfen hat
ORF Kärnten hat den Aktionstag ins Leben
gerufen und Licht ins Dunkel sozusagen
hat
die Verwaltung der Gelder übernommen und
dann die Zuteilung an die Familien an
die Betroffenen und das ist wirklich ein
eingespieltes gutes bewährtes Trio die
Partnerschaft zwischen dem Land und dem
Bundesheer ist eine im positiven Sinn
legendäre kein Kärntner keine Kärnten
vergessen was dieses österreichische
Bundesheer in den verschiedensten
Situationen für unser Bundesland
geleistet hat wir sind hier zuständigen
Dank verpflichtet
[Musik]
lange Partnerschaft oder die unglaublich
wichtig ist so jetzt drückt das ins
Licht das Licht ins Dunkel tut nämlich
denjenigen zu helfen die zu unterstützen
die es wahrscheinlich so schwer haben
wie schon lange nicht und wir leisten ja
nicht nur mit diesen
militärmusikfestival sehr viel sondern
wir tun das mehr über das ganze Land mit
so vielen Veranstaltungen 12.000
Besucherinnen und Besucher erleben über
zweieinhalb Stunden lang musikalische
Unterhaltung von feinsten und Spenden
insgesamt
91.211 € und 88 Cent völlig ins Dunkel
[Musik]